[Musique]
président des Hauts de France a
finalement cédé il participera au
Congrès LR qui désignera le candidat
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
c'est la garantie pour tous les
électeurs de la droite qu'ils auront à
la fin un seul et unique candidat ou une
seule et unique candidate je suis
heureux de voir que Xavier Bertrand
participera à ce congrès et que nous
puissions avoir une campagne de fond on
va profiter de cette primaire interne
puisque c'est encore une fois ce qui a
été retenu pour que chacun exprime son
projet ses engagements deux candidats de
la droite et du centre au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle c'était
l'assurance de perdre là nous avons
l'assurance d'avoir un seul candidat
nous le soutiendrons nous la
soutiendrons c'est le sens de la
démarche qui nous conduit aujourd'hui
avoir une perspective pour l'élection
présidentielle vous avez la certitude
que quel que soit le résultat du vote
des adhérents les perdants le
respecteront alors est-ce que vous
pensez quelque chose oui il faut oui oui
parce que la famille est rassemblée là
ce qui est important la déclaration de
Xavier hier
voilà en plus mais il faut qu'on se
rassembler vous avez hyper chaud au
dessus de la tête
votre épave bien sûr que je voudrais pas
la présidentielle au Congrès bien sûr
que je voudrais et que vous voudrez pour
qui j'ai pas compris pardon
recouvert d'un drap blanc sur la ligne
de chemin de fer les enquêteurs tentent
de comprendre les circonstances de
l'accident que faisaient ces quatre
migrants sur les voies SNCF pourquoi
était-il allongé sur les rails ou à
proximité au moment du passage du train
il semblerait que ces personnes étaient
allongées sans doute se reposer ce qui
est tout à fait plausible le bilan est
extrêmement lourd trois morts et un
blessé grave dans la salle des fêtes de
l'Élysée transformée pour l'occasion des
chefs d'entreprise des étudiants des
entrepreneurs et un chef de l'État qui
déambule sur scène tel un candidat en
campagne diront certains si on fait le
bilan du macronisme on peut voir que
Alstom Lafarge Alcatel technique Essilor
Suez et le prochain CNJ c'est le bilan
destructif de Monsieur Macron la
stratégie pour 2030 doit nous conduire à
investir 30 milliards d'euros pour
répondre justement à ce déficit qui est
le déficit en quelque sorte de
croissance français c'est la campagne de
Monsieur Bricolage cette histoire c'est
à dire qu'on a Emmanuel Macron qui
aujourd'hui fait des sorties fait des
annonces souvent d'ailleurs déjà budgété
et on a l'impression que comme ça il
rase gratis le dernier en date c'est
d'ailleurs Ariane puisqu'on vient de
passer un accord avec les Allemands pour
déménager nos systèmes de poussée de nos
fusées en Allemagne donc maintenant on
fait le made in France en Allemagne pour
produire de l'énergie en particulier
l'électricité nous avons une chance
c'est notre modèle historique
le parc installé
de nucléaire aujourd'hui le nucléaire
nous permet d'avoir une énergie peu
chère et l'Europe nous interdit de
vendre au prix de production et nous
oblige à vendre très cher l'électricité
qu'on produit pourtant pas cher nous
devons absolument nous préparer à des
technologies de rupture et de
transformation profonde sur le nucléaire
la promesse de ce qu'on appelle les
Smalls modulars reactor ce qui sont les
petits réacteurs beaucoup plus modérés
et beaucoup plus sûr le nucléaire est
une chance par-ci le nucléaire est un
atout par là le déni de la réalité et
l'entêtement du président n'ont aucune
limite le gasoil n'a jamais été aussi
cher en france rien contre le premier et
le 8 octobre le litre a augmenté de près
de 4 centimes il atteint aujourd'hui à
la pompe
1,5354 euros en moyenne le fils de
Superman qui s'appelle John Kent et qui
assumera nous dit-on ce sont les
éditeurs qui viennent de l'annoncer dans
cette bande dessinée apparaître en
novembre une relation avec un homme on
va voir Superman enfin le fils de
Superman le nouveau Superman
embrasse un homme et qui officiellement
dira assumer le fait d'être bisexuelle
vous en pensez quoi